Hello Freak bitches were,
I don't know if you've heard of these guys.
Astrophysicist John mattise and Daniel Whitmore from the University of Louisiana
came up with a theory that said that something smaller than a Jovian mass would
not be strong enough to perform this task.
They believe that there's something up to 25% of them.
Okay?
It's four times as big as Jupiter could be responsible for sending these objects
and art direction.
This is just a random theory that these guys put together.
It wasn't completely accepted what they're doing.
No,
no,
no.
There's no,
there's no known such object what you,
what people are doing,
and I don't fault them for it.
It's creative.
It would make awesome science fiction.
Storytelling is,
there's something you need to explain here on earth.
Somebody went extinct.
There were some wave of comets.
There's some observation that was never repeated.
There's some thing you got to come up with and so you say,
well,
we know the Oort cloud exists.
We know you can perturb those orbits and,
and send them careening down towards the inner solar system and those,
that Jupiter doesn't bat away like batting practice,
those that get through Jupiter's gravitational shield could wreak havoc on
earth.
Yeah.
But that's,
it's,
it's inventing a lot to explain something you don't know.
And so it's inventing more of what you don't know.
That could be true to explain what you don't
that which you don't have any other evidence to support.
So it's fun,
speculation,
fun speculation.
Exactly.
Beyond that to say,
oh,
it's real,
it must be happening.
No,
no.
It's just let someone write a good Scifi story on it.
Here's what's fun about it and this is why I bring it up.
Um,
most people I've talked to this about this subject to many,
many people and,
uh,
I,
myself personally,
I'm not immune to this.
I find it very fascinating.
However,
how much have I looked into the actual planets that we absolutely know are real?
Not that much,
but I'm worried about this fucking fake planet that may or may not exist.
Do they might've found another planet.
It's this idea of something hidden and mysterious,
which is so compelling and attractive.
Eczema,
fascinating psychological observation.
It's a weird thing.
We want to believe there's something mysterious that we don't understand and
could be there,
but we don't know anything about yet where there's plenty of things we do know
something about,
but we want to know more.
Why don't you help?
Yes.
All right.
And by the way,
the universe is far more wondrous than anything we can imagine.
And so,
so to say,
I need your creativity and you know,
uh,
to,
to keep your life interesting.
No,
we got black holes that are flaying stars layer by layer.
We've got,
do you realize that if you fall into a black hole,
you will see the entire future of the universe unfold in front of you in a
matter of moments.
And you will emerge into another space time created by the singularity of the
black hole you just fell into.
Just broke the internet,
broke the Hogan.
So,
so let's talk about that.
All right.
Yeah.
You know,
why are we wasting time talking about whether the Saturn five rocket,
I mean,
cause we're fascinating to buy shit that's unproven,
mysterious shit.
Look,
I got a broken brain.
Okay.
There's a reason for me.
Yeah.